je crois au débat quand il est mené deux
bonnes foi et quand il vise à trouver
des solutions communes
en première comme en nouvelle lecture la
commission des affaires sociales a
examiner le texte et les amendements
loyalement les débats ont eu lieu et le
projet de loi a été adopté dans son
intégralité
cependant alors que la nouvelle lecture
devait commencer en séance près de 700
amendements ont été déposés en plus de
ceux adoptés en commission
nous ne pouvons pas perpétuellement
rejouer des débats qui ont été tranchés
nous le pouvons d'autant moins que cela
menacerait le calendrier prévu pour
l'examen du texte et les délais
constitutionnels que nous devons
respecter
or nous avons besoin de cette troisième
partie du projet de loi pour financer
notre modèle social pour offrir des
moyens à notre système de soins pour
venir en aide au plus précaires pour
donner corps à notre politique
d'autonomie aussi mesdames et messieurs
les députés sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la troisième partie du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023
[Applaudissements]